انا الان ادخل الى مركز حزب العداله
والتنميه
كيف اعتقد تسمعين الى جانب الاحتف
الات جدا ولكن حتى الان حسب
مكالمه دول تم فتح 55 بالمئه من الصناديق
اردوغان حصل على
55.80% اما 100 دار اوغلوقه
44.20% طبعا هذه الارقام تتغير
اود الاشاره انه رئيس العليا للانتخابات
اعلن منذ تقريبا نصف ساعه رفع خبر النشر
المتعلق بالجوله الثانيه ولكن اللاصق كان
تصريح لفائض المتحدث باسمي حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي قال اطالب الجميع بمن فيهم
توادرنا الحزبيه وزملائنا من مراقبين
صناديق بتراقب مؤتمر صحفي الساعه السابعه
اي بعد نصف ساعه تقريبا وعدم اعتماد اي
معلومات وبيانات لا تصدر عنها الامر طبعا
الذي ينبئ باستعداد المعارضه التركيه
للتشكيك بالنتائج وكان كذلك دار اوغلو
اليوم تحدث عن حمله ممنهجه
للتشويه يتعرض لها كان هناك ايضا تغريده
للرئيس اردو شكر فيها زملائه الذين عملوا
باخلاص في صناديق الاقتراع منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى وايضا دعاهم للحفاظ على تلك
الصناديق حتى النتائج النهائيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات